i am so excited and you brought this
game to the show yes i did choose this
game i love that i was like anywhere
anytime anything allison wants to do and
then i found out you play it with your
beautiful husband day franco who we've
been just you know talking about the
beauty of your relationship so now i
feel like i'm in the game with you guys
well we'll see if you have his level of
athleticism well
i i don't i can promise you that but i
but i'm excited and like i'm here to
play here's what i'll say about this
game i feel like they're pitting us
against each other like they want us to
have a winner and a loser but the really
the way to make it work is by working
together like i have to want to get your
ring on my horn also
for me it's like hoes before bros i
don't compete with women up to me i'm
like i
we're
we're literally oh and we have a prize
at stake
okay so the game is each of us get four
rings yes and whoever catches the most
rings on their unicorn horn wins and if
i win
this side of the audience
[Applause]
with a prize and if allison wins you
guys are gonna go home
now i gotta
now i gotta do it for real we're playing
we're playing with each other not
against each other but for you guys
we're playing out of love we're playing
only out of love and i'm gonna kill that
side of the room
all right here we go you go first yeah
no i've gotta go okay here's your first
you go first okay oh god okay i'm like
no just do you want me to move or stay
still stay still
all right
[Applause]
i chose this game
oh i was trying to help no maybe i
stopped it it wasn't going in there
anyway
oh my god
[Applause]
i'm more of a receiver than a tosser
harder than it looks it is but i'm so
into this game
we need more rings
oh my god
the crazy thing is i think my side of
the room is going to win
because that's the most
like i have the most rings on my horn
you have one
that's a bad idea i know but you know
what we're just so not that show
all of you you're all going home with
something that's right
i'm sorry
the prize is something i'm so into i
hope you guys are too um spin master
games heard how much we all love games
here and so they're sending everyone in
our audience home with a 50 gift card to
stock your game shop with a great kid
so thank you
and thank you for bringing so much fun
and warmth and love and goodness and
talent and everything that you do and
put out into the world i'm such an uber
fan of yours i have been for so long i'm
so happy to celebrate
[Applause]
right now
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you